what's going on guys in this video i'm
going to break down episode 12 of attack
on titan season 4
in which aaron finally used the power of
the warhammer titan and his army of
supporters turned into full-blown
terrorists
today i'll be talking about all the
parts i felt needed explaining including
why zachary had to die
pig's arrival on parodies island and a
few subtle differences between the anime
and manga
before we begin i'd really appreciate if
you hit the sub button as we are on the
road to 250k
and of course let me know in the
comments what you thought of the episode
okay so episode 12 was called guides and
it starts off with armin trying to get
to second base with annie's titan
crystal
armin's recent obsession with annie is
definitely out of character for him
though when we look at the full context
of everything it's not hard to figure
out why he's doing this
in the four years that annie has been
inside this crystal how many times did
armin go to visit her before he
inherited the colossal titan
my guess is not many i mean we
definitely never saw it and it was never
really implied from anything the
characters said
therefore it's a bit strange that ever
since he inherited bertolt's titan
he seemingly goes to visit annie
whenever he has free time bertolt and
annie obviously knew each other since
childhood
and as we all know he had a massive
crush on her armin's new fascination
with annie is likely because of the
influence of berthold's memories but i
don't think even he realizes that
as he goes to touch the crystal hitch
enters the room at the most awkward
possible moment
with armin visibly getting flustered
trying to explain himself hitch is the
person that usually watches over annie
although from time to time armin will
come in and you know fill in her
a random piece of trivia for those that
might not know is that hitch and annie
used to be squadmates together in the
military police
and their friendship was very briefly
explored in the spin-off manga lost
girls
i say it was a friendship it was more
like an acquaintance and that storyline
happened one day before annie tried to
capture eren
anyway in the present day she hands arm
in a newspaper which helps to explain
the current situation on paradise island
to put it simply floc's plan is working
perfectly as in the last episode he and
a bunch of recruits leaked information
to the public
to raise support for eren's release that
leaked info was able to get a small
group of people to gather outside
military hq
but in this episode as we can see the
support for aaron has exploded pun
intended
citizens across the island are furious
that aaron is being held prisoner
and they perceive the military to be the
bad guys who are unjustly detaining him
to make matters worse the military
hasn't even tried to explain why they're
keeping aaron prisoner which only made
the people more pissed off
in the manga hitch stated that eren's
supporters have surrounded every
military base
so it's almost like there's a revolution
going on mikasa meets armin at military
hq
because as they said a couple episodes
ago their aim is to have a talk with
erin so they can figure out his goals
currently the military's plan is to have
someone they can trust eat aaron so
these two want to save his life
by talking to him and proving he's on
their side the first step in that plan
is to convince zachary to let them see
eren
because as the head of the military
nothing happens without his approval
before they reach his office they notice
there are some new survey corps recruits
at hq
something which never normally happens
new recruits normally have no reason to
be here
but on this occasion they came to bring
zachary's torture device to his office
this is important because that device
had a bomb planted inside it but at this
stage of the episode obviously we didn't
know that
the torture device was previously seen
during the uprising in season 3
where zachary showed his sadistic side
as he tortured nobles
i won't get into the disgusting detail
of how this thing works but just know
that zachary claimed he hated the nobles
and always intended to overthrow them
that's why later in the episode
pixis felt that zachary would have been
somewhat satisfied to die at the hands
of a revolution
after the new recruits made their
appearance the anime switches over to
commander pixis and elena who had been
confronted with some incriminating
information
ever since the malian volunteers arrived
on the island aaron was shown not to
have real contact with any of them
with levi even going out of his way to
stop elaine and talking to him
despite that there was one night around
10 months ago in which flock was
assigned to watch over elena
and as we know this guy is one of erin's
most loyal followers on the night in
question there was a party going on
but elena left early with flock
escorting her back to her house
aaron happened to live not too far away
from that location so you can understand
why pixar suspected something might be
going on
in this episode she straight up admits
that she did meet with aaron that night
although she claimed she did it in the
best interests of the island for three
years now
elena zeke and the other volunteers have
long been suspected of having an
ulterior motive
so the fact she would risk meeting with
aaron in secret is a huge deal at the
time of their meeting 10 months ago
the island of paradise was in a very
vulnerable position because you know
they still had no allies around the
world besides hizaru
and without zeke on the island they
could not use the power of the founding
titan to defend themselves
only with zeke's presence could they use
the rumbling to defend themselves
but the leaders on parodies like hanji
kept on wasting valuable time
aaron agreed to meet elena because he
personally felt that ireland was in
danger
and flock was the middle man that
allowed the meeting to happen we don't
know the true extent of what was
discussed but the fact is that after
elena and aaron made contact
aaron began acting more independently
before eventually going to mali to get
zeke himself
whichever way you look at it this secret
meeting was super suspicious
as it almost looks like elena influenced
erin to do what he did
while there's still no solid evidence
that elena has done anything that's
against parody's island's interests
onyangkapon makes it clear that he had
no idea she met aaron
this confirms for us that if there is
some secret evil plan going on
then not all of the volunteers would
know about it because you know clearly
onyankapon didn't know
and he's essentially her right hand man
his conversation with hanji raises even
more suspicion about elena
because as we know she hates mali and
has never been afraid to kill marlins if
she needs to
despite that since she's been on the
island she's fought for the rights of
malians and even argued that they should
have jobs and other benefits
the question hanji wonders is what
reason could elena have
for wanting malians to integrate onto
parodies in this way even though she you
know she's shown no regard for their
lives in the past
the fact is is that right now we just
don't know her true motivations
although the plot does keep thickening
moving over to zachary's office now
armani mikasa attempted to convince him
to let them speak with aaron
but by then it was already too late by
this point in the day
zachary was made aware of elaine's
secret meeting with aaron and it totally
destroyed the little bit of trust that
they still had left in him
aaron's refusal to say anything only
made them more suspicious with zachary
now believing that aaron is almost like
a puppet of zeke
there is nothing that armando mikasa
could have said in this meeting that
would have redeemed aaron and zachary's
eyes
which is why we see three military
police officers heading towards his
office
one of those mps was most likely going
to be chosen to inherit the founding
titan however aaron supporters had
something to say about that
as they blew up the candidates alongside
zachary himself
from this point of the video i'll be
referring to the group of aaron
supporters as the jaegers
and from their perspective this act of
terrorism was necessary for two main
reasons
reason number one is that with the
military's plan to transfer the founding
titan to another person
they felt they had no choice but to take
action and kill the potential successors
by doing what they did there is now no
chance that the military will try to act
in the same way
secondly flock already made it clear
that they want aaron to leave parodies
island
and with zachary now dead the military
is destabilized to an extent
this confusion leaves a potential void
for the jaegers to seize power
it was interesting that after this
surprise attack aaron's mob of
supporters outside of hq
were energized by these events as they
saw it as the beginning of eren's
revolution
i'm just surprised that so many regular
civilians seem to be just cool with
seeing a dead body like that
like even if you support aaron surely
this is a horrifying thing to witness
in a quick emergency meeting between the
three military branches plus on yankapon
they quickly begin to review the
situation armin realizes that it was the
new survey corps recruits that planted
the bomb
much to everyone's horror but i gotta
say it's peculiar
that so many new recruits seem to be
anti-establishment
last week we saw how certain new
recruits have been helping to leak
information about eren
and now other recruits are assassinating
the commander-in-chief
at this stage in the episode things were
definitely beginning to turn in eren's
favor
but it was topped off by the outstanding
reveal that the man himself had now
escaped from his underground cell
using the power of the weimar titan
aaron was able to dig an underground
tunnel from which to escape
although the anime didn't show this part
happening aaron sealed off his escape
route with titan hardening so that no
one in the military could chase after
him
we got this awesome sequence of aaron
walking towards his supporters like some
kind of prophet
and it's clear that he spent at least
some time in jail doing crunches
flock and the other jaegers were able to
escape because there are many prison
guards on parodies who believe in eren's
cause
and in fact those are the guards who
told aaron what day in time to break out
like flock said the group here is a
small fraction of errant supporters
so it really does seem like the pieces
are in place for him to take over the
island
right now his only goal is to find zeke
because once that happens it's game over
for anyone who would try to stop them
with the full power of the founding
titan aaron would basically be
invincible
and could protect the island from
invading forces by whatever means
necessary
willy typer warned that eren could
destroy the world and with aaron and
zeke working together
that possibility becomes a reality this
moment with aaron putting on his hoodie
is possibly one of the most iconic ever
moments from the manga
so i was genuinely intrigued to see how
they would do it overall it looks
fantastic i mean
he definitely seems more aggressive in
the anime which is great because it
conveys his determination even better
next up the military leaders organized a
new meeting with kiyomi having the most
awkward seat in the house
she arrived in the last episode to
witness the partial test of the rumbling
which would have happened if these mps
were not assassinated instead of that
she's been caught up in the middle of a
civil war and watches on as the mps
bicker with the survey corps
the arrival of pixis brought some
stability to the meeting but
ultimately his game plan is to surrender
to eren when we look back at past
seasons
pixis has always put the needs of
humanity ahead of his own personal
preferences
and he always chooses the practical
options that result in the least
bloodshed
from his point of view they can avoid
unnecessary deaths by negotiating with
the jaegers in good faith
pixis is smart here because he knows
that the aegis want to find out where
zeke is
and only people within the military like
hanji know that information
by using knowledge of zeke's location to
their advantage pixis can negotiate some
kind of agreement
that would prevent a civil war from
breaking out as the meeting ends
kiyomi assures mika said that if
everything goes to hell the offer is
open for mikasa to flee to his roof if
she wants
although mikasa declined through their
conversation we realized an important
truth about kiyomi and that's that she
doesn't care who rules the island
all that matters to her is that parodies
is able to perform a rumbling with the
colossal titans in the walls
because that's the only thing that can
protect their investment remember that
for the last three years
his rule has been mining the iceberg
stone from paradise and using it to
develop new technologies
like this flying boat as long as the
island has the rumbling as a defense
then his ru are destined to make a ton
of profit because they're the only other
nation that is allowed to access the
iceber stone
without the rumbling to defend
themselves other nations like mali could
blitz the island and potentially steal
those resources for themselves
that is one of the reasons why mali
initially invaded parodies with the
warriors and although that reason is not
really spoken about much
we know from grishaig's flashback that
they wanted the resources
with that said it is still true that
kyomi does care about mikasa
and genuinely wants to protect her
regardless of what happens
the episode ends with the survey core
riding on horseback to explore a hunch
that hanji hopes
might reveal elena's true intentions
restaurants are one of the places that
marley and workers operate
and the scene pans to sasha's family as
they arrived to the restaurant where
they were invited to come by nicolo
today is that day when they all arrive
and you'll see that gabby and falca were
also present after kai invited them to
come along
these two know nicolo is amalian so
they're hoping to meet him so
we'll see what's happening with that in
the next episode whilst the survey
called gallop on their horses
we see none other than peak in the
background who has infiltrated parodies
island
we don't currently know where the other
warriors are but peak's presence in the
city could only be for one reason
she mentioned how mali couldn't afford
to lose gabby and falco
so she's most likely here to collect
them before marley rains down hellfire
on the island
it's super impressive that pique was not
only able to just infiltrate the island
but also able to locate important
characters like armin mikasa and hanji
so quickly if you gave her some more
time i reckon she'd probably find zeke
before the jaeger is due
with that said that was my breakdown for
episode 12 of attack on titan season 4
in which things are really getting
intense as usual i'd appreciate if you
dropped a like if you liked the video
and let me know in the comments what you
thought of this episode until the next
one
peace out